>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE COFOUNDERS OF
FUSION GPS THE RESEARCH COMPANY
BEHIND THE TRUMP DOSSIER CLAIMED
AND THEIR COMPANY.
THEY DEMANDED CONGRESS RELEASED
TRIPLETS OF TESTIMONY BY THEIR
MAYBE WE WILL FIND OUT WHY
FUSION GPS REFUSEED TO HAVE ITS
LEADERS TESTIFY PUBLICLY.
TONIGHT I CALL ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO DECLASSIFY ALL
DOCUMENTS AND ALL TESTIMONY
CONCERNING THE HILLARY CLINTON
FUSION GPS.
THE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
TRANSPARENCY FROM THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
UNLESS NATIONAL SECURITY MATTERS
ARE INVOLVED, WITH EVERYTHING ON
THE LINE AND ALL OF THE
CONCERNS, LET'S SHED DAYLIGHT ON
THIS SORID MESS.
WE WILL SEE WHO IS COLLUDING
WITH WHOM.
LET'S TURN TO A PAIR OF
REPORTERS WHO HAVE BEEN ALL OVER
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" KIM.
WE HAVE BREAK NEWS FROM DAVID
NUNES.
ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENTS THEY
HAVE BEEN SEEKING SINCE AUGUST
FOR FUSION GPS.
NUNES MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT HALF
AN HOUR AGO.
>> Laura: KIM, DO YOU THINK
THERE IS -- IT'S AMAZING WHAT
THE THREAT OF A CONTEMPT OF
>> PAUL RYAN GETS A LOT OF
CREDIT HERE.
WE JUST WISH HE HAD DONE IT
SOONER.
THIS IS WHAT IT TOOK.
THESE GUYS HAVE BEEN GIVING
NUNES AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE A RUN AROUND SINCE
AUGUST WHICH THE SUBPOENAS FIRST
WENT OUT.
THEY HAD EXCUSES, ALL BOGUS.
MY FAVORITE THEY COULD NOT TALK
BECAUSE OF AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATION AS IF THAT TRUMPED
CONGRESS.
HE SAID IF YOU DON'T HAND THESE
OVER, YOU WILL BE BROUGHT UP ON
CONTEMPT CHARGES.
LET'S HOPE THEY COMPLY AND STOP
WITH THE GAMES.
>> Laura: JOHN, THIS FUSION GPS
DEAL AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
TODAY.
THEY GOT THEIR HANDS ON THIS
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THEY ARE BEING PUT UPON.
THEY WANT TO RELEASE TRANSCRIPTS
OF BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
INTERVIEWS ON THE HILL.
COULDN'T THEY JUST TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY SAID?
>> I WISH THEY WOULD.
WE WOULD LEARN ABOUT THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH THE FBI AND WE
WOULD LEARN THINGS THEY SAID
ABOUT THE FBI THAT MIGHT NOT BE
FLATTERING AND WE MIGHT LEARN
ABOUT CHRISTIAN AND WHETHER ALL
OF THE THINGS HE SAID IN PUBLIC
ARE TRUE.
>> Laura: AND THE WORK THEY DID
FOR RUSSIA.
THEY DID A LOT OF WORK FOR
RUSSIA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MEETING WITH
DON JR. AT THE TRUMP TOWER, THEY
HAD A CONNECTION TO THOSE
PEOPLE.
WE NEED A LOT MORE TRANSPARENCY.
HEARD STEVE BANNON COMMENTS.
NOW WE HAVE INFORMATION THAT
THAT'S WHY I WANT ALL OF THIS
DECLASSIFIED AND RELEASED.
IT'S ABOUT TIME THIS WHOLE THING
WRAPPED UP.
EVERYBODY'S CARDS SHOULD BE ON
THE TABLE AND GET THIS OVER.
>> SHE DID NOT JUST MEET WITH
THEM.
SHE MET WITH GLENN SIMPSON IN
THE HOURS BEFORE WE WENT TO
TRUMP TOWER AND IN THE HOURS
AFTER SHE LEFT TRUMP TOWER.
HE CLAIMS IS NO CONNECTION
IT LOOKS AS THOUGH CONGRESS HAS
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT EVEN
EXPOSING SOURCES AND METHODS.
WHEN YOU ARE AT A LEVEL THIS
HIGH.
WHEN YOU HAVE ACCUSATIONS ON ONE
SIDE THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
ENGAGED IN A CONSPIRACY WITH A
FOREIGN POWER AND ACCUSATIONS ON
THE OTHER THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WERE IN A
BAD WAY TAPPING AMERICANS AND
INVESTIGATION, THOSE ARE
SERIOUS.
YOU DON'T TRUST THAT TO A
COMMISSION OR A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
YOU LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
THE DOCUMENTS AND WORK IT
THROUGH THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: ANYTHING ON COLLUSION?
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS TIME GO BY.
THEY INTERVIEWED ALL OF THESE
WITNESSES AND WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS FROM THE LOWER
STAFFERS TO THE UPPER-TIER.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS INVOLVED IN
COLLUSION.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT ONE FAMILY
MEMBER AND CONVERSATIONS WE HAD
BASED ON INFORMATION THAT MIKE
FLYNN PROVIDED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PULLING BACK
YESTERDAY, I THINK WE HAVE A
>> THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS THAT
THE REVELATION OF PAPADOPOULOS
WHICH WAS NOT A NAME ON MY RADAR
SCOPE.
>> Laura: KIM YOUR REACTION TO
CLAPPER THERE?
>> WELL, WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT INSPIRED THIS INVESTIGATION
AND NOT THE DISCREDITED DOSSIER.
LAST YEAR THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
SAID IT WAS THE DOSSIER THAT DID
IT.
NOW IT'S BEEN DISCREDITED.
NOW IT'S GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
TO FIND OUT THE HEAD OF
INTELLIGENCE DOESN'T KNOW THIS
GUY'S NAME.
HE WAS NOT ON HIS RADAR SCREEN
AT THE TIME HE WAS LEAVING
OFFICE.
IT'S ANOTHER REASON TO BE
SKEPTICAL OF THE NOTION THAT IT
WAS SOME 28-YEAR-OLD JUNIOR